it's definitely been something that I
had to kind of pinch myself
I know pinch myself such a cliche thing
to say but I understand why people say
it now because it's definitely been like
a pinch me the whole experience you know
I it just doesn't feel real you know
when something's your dream for so long
and it's just so like up in the air out
of reach when it finally happens it's
just really hard to grasp and understand
that you're really doing it so it's
definitely felt like a dream this whole
thing is just like now I know you've got
to release the EP very recently yeah
have you already started thinking future
Ford was and is starting to work on a
full-length album or where it where you
musically right now well the album is
done so we have the album it's finished
we just released the EP just has a
little feeler for the album but I'm just
really excited to release the album
we're getting like the booklet together
but all the songs are there and they're
done and just ready to be out I'm so
excited so how would you describe the
album we haven't got to hear any of it
yet so how about the album
I'd say the album is an extended version
of what the EP is sonically and
conceptually it's very much you know
continuing the theme of me as a teenage
girl and my thoughts on the world and
life and feelings and then sonically
there's some pop elements there's
alternative stuff some ballads it's just
a mixture of just my influences in ten
songs